cop 26 cop 26. we're just weeks away now
from cop26 oh you've probably heard the
words cop26 quite a lot by now it is
crucial that these meetings in glasgow
have success the climate conference will
see tens of thousands of people from
almost every country arrive in glasgow
to witness supposedly historic
agreements on climate change
[Music]
197 countries are gearing up to attend
it is the biggest climate event since
the paris agreement was signed in 2015.
cop stands for conference of the parties
the united nations have been holding
climate change summits for the last
three decades and this will be the 26th
they are attended by heads of state
climate experts and campaigners and
their purpose is to produce an
international response to the climate
emergency the uk will co-host the 12-day
event with italy and take over glasgow's
sec centre
we
either
rise up and tackle climate change
together or else we sink together into
the maya this year at cop 26 will be the
moment at which the world chooses which
of those two fates awaits us
[Music]
to understand why cop 26 is so important
we need to look back at cop 21 which is
when the paris agreement was signed in
2015.
the paris summit was the largest
gathering of world leaders in history
for the first time ever nearly every
country on earth agreed to work together
to limit global warming to well below
two degrees
we do need to take action this year and
make sure that at cop26 we are able to
credibly say that we have kept 1.5
degrees alive
the un has said without drastic action
the world is on course to break through
that target within a decade crucially
when all those countries signed the
paris agreement they didn't have to say
exactly what they do to meet their
commitments
at cop26 they'll have to present their
plans known as nationally determined
contributions or ndcs the success of the
conference will be judged by how
ambitious and binding these plans are
world leaders climate experts and
activists are expected to attend this
year's climate summit america said cop
26 must be pivotal in tackling climate
change a pivotal moment for the world to
come together to meet and master the
climate challenge having withdrawn from
the paris agreement under donald trump
the paris accord would undermine our
economy and put us at a permanent
disadvantage it is time to exit the
paris accord the us is expected to play
a leading role at cop 26 under joe biden
we've already waited too long to deal
with this climate crisis who returned
america to the paris accord hours after
becoming president today the united
states is officially once again a party
to the paris agreement which we helped
put together the u.s and china have
butted heads in the months leading up to
cop 26. we understand that there are
problems in the relations between the us
and china a stalemate between the two
superpowers emerged as america called on
china to be more ambitious with its
targets but those problems do not
interfere with the needs to do
everything possible to make sure that
the cop is a success china is the
world's biggest greenhouse gas emitter
but insists it will pursue its own
climate goals and become carbon neutral
by 2060.
we can also expect to see some famous
faces at this year's climate summit with
the queen and the pope in attendance
you worry about the future of the planet
and what kind of award we will live for
future generations
from her majesty to climate royalty
greta tunberg had previously said she
wouldn't attend cop 26 due to safety
concerns and covet 19 vaccination
distribution
where do we want it
but the face of climate change has
changed her mind and is likely to play a
key role at the conference it's on the
school holiday so i don't have to take
time off
climate finance will be a sticking point
at cop26 generally speaking the world's
richest nations have done the most to
cause the climate crisis which is
experienced most severely by poorer
nations a group of industrialized
countries including the uk and u.s
promised to help developing countries
tackle climate change in 2009 but they
missed their targets those funds were
promised to arrive by 2020 and we are
still waiting some think finding
solutions to supporting more climate
vulnerable nations will be the key
factor in the success of cop26
but the main issue will be whether what
is agreed at cop26 will be enough to
limit the worst impacts of global
warming countries like india and
australia and china and south africa are
still struggling to agree on how to
phase out coal and whether or not they
should come forward with better more
enhanced ambitions for reducing carbon
emissions
about 10 000 officers from around the uk
will police each day of cop 26 making it
one of the biggest operations of its
kind in britain the cost of policing the
event has been estimated at around 250
million pounds police are expecting the
potentially historic event to be the
focus of large-scale demonstrations they
have been taking part in role-play
exercises to recreate protests ahead of
cop26
if cop26 goes well there could be new
alliances new emissions targets new
financial commitments made and that
would be real progress it's why there's
such pressure on cop26 and why it's been
described as the world's last best hope
to limit global warming